all right I did a video giving my
thoughts on the soul of a Star Wars
story teaser trailer and as expected for
a Star Wars video produce the kind of
comments I need for soloist Star Wars
story teaser trailer review and at the
end of this video I'll be reacting to
some of your reactions to the solo a
Star Wars story trailer that you tagged
me in on the star test app stick around
for that are you ready I was born let's
get into it
I quit on Star Wars I will support
Marvel movies this year lay the way
Disney is smiling in your general
direction
all hail Skynet for some reason I want
this movie to prove him wrong so hard
Star Wars still remains the tip of the
spear for me that is not based and named
alone to be clear I'm not saying the
movie is going to be crap I'm saying I
have my doubts and the trailer didn't
put those doubts at ease the trailer
didn't make me go oh that's why I
shouldn't have doubted if it means
anything I want the movie to prove me
wrong also Christopher Pyne kinda look
like Kirk he had his own style but he
channeled Jim in all the right ways I
don't see that here with this guy
playing han han was no pretty boy he was
a cowboy this guy sorta reminds me of
Pratt but not funny
I don't know I'm jaded that is the
perfect example that's the example I'm
just unable to think of it's Chris Pine
as james t kirk chris pine wasn't doing
a William Shatner impersonation which
sounds
amazingly horrible or horribly amazing
in either case he gave james t kirk his
own spin he played his own version of
kirk which kept the essence of the
character but felt different if alden
ehrenreich plays that up if he plays
that same angle Chris Pine played for
Kirk as applied to han Solo
I feel like that would work for me I
mean I'd like to see him do that but we
will see time will tell is it me or does
Jeremy seem angrier these days and he
was say a few years ago I mean he's
crashing way more and doesn't seem to
get excited about things that used to
excite him Star Wars in Jurassic Park
look at the video I made nearly eight
years ago called do I really cost that
much and in that respect have I really
changed I mean I say [ __ ] more nowadays
but that's just because I don't give a
[ __ ] as for getting excited for Jurassic
Park ins
starwars I still love Star Wars I still
love Jurassic Park but I'm not going to
get excited for all things Jurassic Park
and Star Wars just because they are
Jurassic Park and Star Wars as I'm going
to assume you are a fan of mine does
that mean you love all 1356 videos I
have done I'm going to assume not
because that would be statistically
impossible in that respect I assume you
understand Star Wars fans are the worst
and that includes you Jeremy quite being
so jaded it's a movie it looks fun and
I'm excited to see more without using
absolute statements like our I will say
Star Wars fans can be the worst when
they become finger pointing zealots
telling someone how they need to view a
franchise or a movie coming out in that
franchise yes that was supposed to be
ironic and aimed at you dude enough with
the f-bombs that can't always listen to
you wearing headphones and my parents /
colleagues here in India gives me weird
looks when they listen to you on
speakers oh that [ __ ] sucks just stay
with the OT films dude you just / Force
awakens but [ __ ] it on last Jedi foul
was good but last Jedi was amazing and
now you basically don't care about this
movie just stay in the seventies
eighties dude leave the rest of us have
celebrate Star Wars in modern times
yeah I'm not telling you how you need to
view Star Wars or any other franchise
I'm just telling you how I view it I
view Star Wars kind of like currency the
more dollars that are in circulation the
less the dollar is worth I kind of see
it like Star Wars it was one in a
million and I feel like it's in danger
of exchanging that for becoming one of
the millions however I have done exactly
what you said you want me to do I'm over
here celebrating Star Wars how I
celebrate Star Wars leaving you to
celebrate Star Wars how you celebrate
Star Wars I didn't come to your door did
I ring your doorbell and be like
dingdong hello have you heard my message
on my viewpoint of Solo a Star Wars
story or its trailer no not at all I'm
just over here in my space which happens
to be my YouTube channel just doing my
thing giving my opinion you sought me
out so you can't just be like go to your
space and give your opinion on Star Wars
which is exactly what you're doing
all right now I'm gonna [ __ ] about how
you're not doing but all things coming
around all things being a circle in the
year 2040 or whenever they will have a
new iteration of Star Wars that you
won't like and you'll [ __ ] about it and
whatever boneyard monstrosity social
media we will have at that time where
the world will have at that time and
you'll be like I don't like it and
someone will be like just go back to
2017-18 and leave us to celebrate Star
Wars here in modern times so just wait
for it it'll happen apparently it's
happened to me now so I [ __ ] Skywalker
Ranch George Lucas is laughing his ass
off true if I had four billion [ __ ]
dollars I would have very little to
[ __ ] about myself okay
oh that is a completely reasonable
comment completely reasonable person
funny thing I get comments like that
sometimes on social media I get it on
Twitter I'll get it in the comments
section but never at a convention if
anyone ever meets me they're never a
dick so I got to assume some dicks
online I have met at conventions but
they're never dicks there so I kind of
see dick comments like that as road rage
like something you will say when there's
a separation of reality but something
that you're not gonna say in person but
a little word to the wise don't wish
someone death in written form on the
Internet just not smart just saying dude
he has to grow he can't be new Hope Solo
right off the bat people do change in
time but to correct a statement I said
in my video I shouldn't have said he
doesn't feel like Han Solo I should have
said does they feel like Han Solo
I don't know because the trailer didn't
give me enough data to assess that it's
just the fact that they just gave us a
couple of lines we don't have enough to
say whether or not he feels like Han
Solo that in and of itself is the
problem that's the thing I don't like
you look at the trailer for the first
Iron Man movie Iron Man one came out in
2008 the trailer dropped in 2007 at that
time people really didn't give a [ __ ]
about Marvel movies
there was no Marvel Cinematic Universe
people didn't give a [ __ ] about Robert
Downey jr. people did not really give a
[ __ ] about Iron Man I thought the movie
was going to be a piece of [ __ ] but I
saw that teaser trailer and I was like
movies gonna be terrible but he is going
to be great in it that
trailers sold me on Robert Downey jr.
being Tony Stark I was instantly excited
that's what this trailer should have
done I wish the solo trailer that hit
for months before the solo movie came
out did what the Iron Man trailer that
hit eight months before Iron Man came
out did if you want to see how to sell
the audience on a character and a
casting watch that teaser trailer for
the first Ironman it's awesome loved the
last Jedi and I am going to love this go
one with an open mind instead of
deciding beforehand you already hate the
movie you might actually enjoy Star Wars
well I don't think this movie's gonna be
a piece of [ __ ] or anything I don't
think I'm gonna hate it but if I'm going
to poke holes in your comment going into
a movie with a preconceived notion is
not a guarantee that you're going to see
a movie a certain way there are movies
that I was convinced I was going to love
the movie that I didn't like movies that
I was convinced I was going to hate the
movie that I actually love and if we're
all being honest with ourselves and each
other it is virtually impossible for
someone to go into an event to which
they have prior experience of joy or
disdain and be truly emotionally or
sentimentally agnostic it's just it's
not the way people work and if you think
you're exempt you're not you're
open-mindedness in going into the movie
convinced that you are going to like it
is a preconceived notion that you have
so that in and of itself seems to be
what you claim not to like it may be in
the opposite end of the spectrum from a
spectrum you don't like but it is still
going into a movie with a preconceived
notion and here's one for the reverse
when I went into 50 shades of free do
you think I went into that movie with
any other mindset other than this
movie's gonna suck ass and I'm going to
[ __ ] destroy it when I review it no I
actually got the silly string and the
party hat and had all the party devices
I got that before I even watched the
movie I went to the store on the way to
the screening because I was like I'm
going to murder this [ __ ] thing does
anybody care no because it's a
preconceived notion that people want me
to have so it's not that people don't
want me to have a preconceived notion is
that they don't want me to have a
preconceived notion that is in the
opposite spectrum of a preconceived
notion they want me to have it as I said
we all have preconceived notions and I
feel like if we're all just honest about
that and we accept that fact I feel like
we can at least eliminate
some of the friction it causes among
people talk in movies or really anything
all right and like I said I put a cult
alarms out there on Twitter to say hey
react to the solo star wars story
trailer on Stardust and then I will use
some of your reactions in this video and
I'll bounce off of them I'll kind of
react to them so that's what we're gonna
do we're gonna let this [ __ ] take a
hike sorry go ahead and take a seat what
what dude is fun we're doing it for the
fans the fans get to have more
interaction this way tell you what after
this Stardust reaction segment I will
give you the last comment you can do the
last thing to finish the video wat that
cool all right let's get to you folks
the more I watch the trailer the more
worried I get and the more excited it's
a weird love and hate I like the
aesthetic I like maybe what they're
gonna try to do but I'm not sure I like
the personality that they're really
giving Han it was kind of something
different in my head but whatever I like
what Lando looks like I like that
gambling scene that was cool maybe he
loses the Falcon there but I don't know
I don't want to see him how he gets his
blast how he gets his code I don't want
to see that how he gets his boots I
don't know do you think they're gonna do
that we'll see that is the struggle with
Solo in Star Wars fans right now isn't
it where it's like I see the concept I
enjoy the concept I see the potential do
I like what I see do I like everything
I've heard not necessarily I feel like
they're gonna have nods for some of the
things I don't want to see where they he
gets everything else I don't care where
he got his Wester his blaster his vest
he got at Target because it was on sale
for all I give a [ __ ]
the Falcon looks so different I've
actually humored in my mind like maybe
it's another ship of the same design not
the Millennium Falcon we will see what
they do but I got it I feel it everybody
needs to take a step back
chill wait for the movie to come out and
then make your own opinion on it like
what are you guys complaining about it
looks great and Ron Howard took over the
reins for this lake hey I think this
film is in pretty good hands we get to
see how Hahn meets Chuy we get to see a
young Lando played by Childish Gambino I
mean it has all the right recipes for
success why are you guys making it out
to seem like it's gonna be terrible
first of all love the energy glad you're
pumped and you do bring up a good point
about Ron Howard taken over the reins
I'm gonna stick to here which is Ron
Howard came on after Lord and Miller
were fired
we're heard there were a lot of
production problems so it's easy to lump
in the production problems of Lord and
Miller - what Ron Howard is doing but
really if you look at it it's a
different product entirely I feel like
Ron Howard we did 90% of this movie so
everything you heard about Lord and
Miller pre was June 2017 just go ahead
and scrap that stick to the Ron Howard
thing I do think he is a good person to
take over because he has history with
George Lucas and I feel like he does
know the characters a bit more but for
his filmography I'm kind of 50/50 on Ron
Howard he has made some great stuff he
has made some Knox or great stuff so
time will tell but for the sake of your
energy my man I want you to walk out of
that movie going I tell them though it's
a mixed bag I mean seeing Donald Glover
slander makes me really excited but
Alden Ehrenreich performance as han Solo
in the trailer leaves me wanting I mean
we haven't seen a lot about it so he
might be better in the movie other than
that the effects look really cool and it
looks like it was gonna be a really
great sci-fi movie
let's hope solar works all star wars
bias aside I thought it looked at least
really cool I can see where people are
coming from how it doesn't really have
the Star Wars feel and a lot of people
didn't even want this and the production
issues are a big lag on the film but I
think we're gonna get a pretty decent
flick and I think it's gonna be pretty
cool pretty fun ride that's what I got
from the trailer I put these two
reactions back-to-back because they're
pretty much going about it the same way
they're going about it which i think is
a healthy way which is look it's not
gonna be this religious Star Wars
experience it's not gonna be this
once-in-a-lifetime thing it's not going
to be this special thing it's going to
be probably a fun sci-fi adventure
maybe we're used to Star Wars being more
than that but I feel like that's what
solos going to be so I agree with them I
agree with you guys I'm trying to see it
like that - it's funny how Donald Glover
can literally say nothing and still I
can see multiple news articles about him
that is true the constant or common
notion is that Donald Glover was great
in the trailer and he said nothing so I
guess less is true
is more and here it is folks the last
reaction the final reaction and this
dude is as real as I have ever seen if
you want to see the reality of the
soloist Star Wars story trailer the fan
notion the fans in general that this guy
speaks for all of us enjoy the valley of
the real honestly I need to see more
footage from so low a Star Wars story
before I make my decision if I'm excited
before or not I know I'll go see it I
love that dude love the fact he's like I
don't know but I'm gonna say it so I
wish I could withhold my opinion
generally speaking everyone has an
opinion I wish I could withhold it more
but as I do have a youtube channel that
is built around talking about movies I
kind of I give my opinion out there it's
just kind of what I do if I kept it that
real my videos would be 11 seconds long
which I guess is why Stardust is perfect
for that sort of thing so thank you all
for the comments thank you all for the
reactions if I cut them down a little
bit to save time I apologize for that
maybe I can make it its own thing
instead of putting it at the end of
tales from the comments section I can
make tales from Stardust or something so
I wouldn't have to slice up the
reactions to save time but did you have
fun yeah so remember to follow the link
below to the Stardust app follow me
first it's really important because it
makes the day at Stardust Inc I'm
actually the [ __ ] follow me there and
when there's something I'm going to
feature Stardust reactions and I'll let
you know and start us or keep an eye out
for that thank you all for the reactions
and as promised we give the last comment
to do shimi take it away we're gonna
teach Jeremy to punch properly oh I got
this and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]